la prueba de papanicolaou es una prueba
que detecta el cáncer cervical u otras
enfermedades del cuello uterino el
cuello uterino es la parte inferior del
útero y se encuentra por encima de la
vagina
la prueba de papanicolaou se utiliza
para verificar si hay células anormales
en el cuello uterino si no se recibe
tratamiento las células anormales a
veces pueden convertirse en cáncer
cervical
la prueba de papanicolaou puede formar
parte de un examen pélvico en primer
lugar el proveedor de atención médica
colocará un instrumento llamado especuló
dentro de la vagina el espéculo se
abrirá para que se pueda observar el
cuello uterino a continuación el
proveedor utilizará un raspador o un
cepillo para recoger suavemente las
células del cuello uterino
las células serán examinadas en un
laboratorio bajo un microscopio para ver
si alguna de ellas es anormal
por lo general se obtienen los
resultados de la prueba en una a tres
semanas
si tiene preguntas sobre esta prueba o
los resultados de la prueba hablé con su
proveedor